[موسيقى]
هي فرصه للاحتفال بانسانيتنا المشتركه
واحترام اختلافاتنا هكذا يصف ضيفنا
مونديال قطر 2022 ولعلها فرصه ايضا لتغيير
صوره النمطيه سلبيه عن العالم العربي
كبسها الغرب عبر الزمن من خلال افلامه
واقلامه وحتى احلامه عن هذا الشرق الذي
يراه حلما في ليله من الف ليله وتاره
كابوسا يقض مرجعه بتخلفه عن معايير العالم
المتحضر لكن الواقع الذي يرسمه هذا
المونديال اليوم وفق ضيفنا هو عالم عربي
استطاع ان يفتك بجداره واستحقاق حق تنظيم
اكبر حدث رياضيا في العالم سيصنع من خلاله
التاريخ وسيقدم العالم العربي بنسخته
الاضحى وبينما تتسارع دقات ساعه العد
التنازلي الانطلاق كافره البدايه للبطوله
يؤكد القائمون على الحدث على قدره الرياضه
على احداث التغيير الايجابي في المجتمعات
وفي ان تكون الجسرا بين الشعوب وتحقيقا في
هذه الغايه ترعى اللجنه العليا للمشاريع
والارث في قطر بالتعاون مع الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم فيفا برنامج التطوع للمشاركه
في تنظيم فعاليات المونديال قربت نصف
مليون انسان من انحاء العالم تنافس ليكون
بين 20,000 متطوع في تنظيم المونديال قطر
في رساله تبدو بليغه في الرد على الحملات
وعلى الدعوات بمقاطعه المونديال التي
تنطلق من عواصم غرب غربيه تتستر برعايه
حقوق الانسان وتغفل عن جرائم الكراهيه
والعنصريه على ارضها في قصتنا الليله تحدي
مونديال قطر فقط فريقنا خمسه من المتطوعين
يمثلون خلفيات مختلفه لنتعرف على قصصهم
ودوافعهم لتطوع في هذا المونديال وعن
تصوراتهم المسبقه لقطر والمنطقه العربيه
عموما وعما وجدوته على ارض الواقع نستكمل
بقيه القصه مع السيد حسن الذوادي الامين
العام للاجنه العليا للمشاريع والارث وقد
رافق رحله ملف قطر منذ ان كان حلما طموحا
الى انباته واقعا تعيشه قطر ويننتظره
الملايين نساله عن التحديات المستمره امام
البطوله حتى قبيل انطلاقها كيف يراها وكيف
سيتم التعامل معها وعن الارث الذي سيتركه
المونديال للاجيال القادمه وعن طموحات قطر
المستقبليه في تنظيم احداث عالميه الكبرى
نشاهد والقصه ونبدا الحوار
[تصفيق]
مع اقتراب ساعه الصفر واتجاه انظار العالم
نحو قطر تشهد الاستضافه العربيه الاولى في
التاريخ لكاس العالم تشتد وتيره هجمات
الشرسه سيقت على مدار 12 عاما الا انها لم
تمنع نصف مليون شخص في مختلف انحاء العالم
من الاقبال على اكبر برنامج تطوع رياضي
لدعم مونديال قطر 2022 في سابقه هي الاعلى
بين برامج تطوع كاس العالم
وكان شو توداينتاير وورلد ضد قطر
2022 نتكلم عن اول مره يستوي هذا الحدث
عندنا في الوطن العربي
فاكيد جميع العيون علينا ولهذا تم
الاستعداد لهذه البطوله من اكثر من 10
سنوات
قام قرابه نصف مليون شخص ينتمون لاكثر من
100 و80 دوله حول العالم بالتسجيل لبرنامج
التطوعي لتنظيم كاس العالم في قطر
الفرصه تطوعيه وتم تحديد الادوار لكل فرصه
من فرص التطوعيه لتم اعدادها سابقا وطبعا
هذا الشيء يبنى على توزيع الجغرافي اللي
محتاجين في التنوع اللي راح يكون فيه
العمر اللي احنا نركز عليه مثلا بطوله كاس
العالم لازم 18 سنه وما فوق والاحتياج
وطبيعه الاحتياج هل نحتاجها في الميديا في
الاعلام في الترانسبورتيشن في المواصلات
في التذاكر في الملعب همم اداره الجمهور
كلها انواع مختلفه
وتحدد قبل ما يتم اختيار المتطوع
[تصفيق]
من الفلبين والذي يعمل مديرا ومهندسا في
مجال الانشاءات تم قبوله مع ابنته كيسي في
برنامج التطوع
الى برنامج التطوع لانه سيكون احد اهم
الانشطه التي سنفعلها طوال حياتنا
وسنشارككم عن احداثه الممتعه الاولى
انا
وعمري 29 عاما
[تصفيق]
تطوعين بهذه البطوله
الى صفات مثل الحماس واظهار الشغف لما
تريد القيامه به واعتقد ان الفريق
الاختيار ادرك انني امتلك مثل هذه الصفات
ولذلك قام باختياري وهناك سبب اضافي وهو
انهم لم يتمكنوا من مقاومه ابتسامه
الجميله لانني ابتسم دائما لذلك اعتقد ان
هذه احدى الصفات التي جعلتهم
[تصفيق]
سيتوزع المتطوعون على 45 من طاقه تشغيليه
للعمل في 30 دور وظيفيه وسيكون هدف هذه
الادوار مجتمعه تقديم الدعم والمساهمه في
انجاح كافه جوانب العمليات التشغيليه خلال
هذه البطوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الموارد البشريه والقياده حيث كان يبحثون
عن اشخاص يمكن ان يكونوا قاده وربما
يواجهون ويدربون الاخرين اثناء قيامهم
بتوزيع البرنامج وكذلك اراد اشخاصا لديهم
بعض المعرفه بالموارد البشريه هذا اشبه
بتعيين موظفين رائعين
[تصفيق]
الو مرحبا
[موسيقى]
سيكون دوري في نهائيات كاس العالم لكره
القدم قطر 2022 في اداره القوى العامله
وستكون مسؤوليه المحدده توزيع زي الرسمي
لجميع المتطوعين وهذا يتماشى مع شغفي
بالموضه ستكون مهمتي التاكد من ان كل شخص
يبدو جيدا وجذابا امام الاشخاص الذين
يخدموهم ومن خلال مهمته هذا ساحقق شرفي في
مجال الازياء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مركز تبدا رحله التدريب للمتطوعين من خلال
300 جلسه تدريب حيث سيخضع المتطوعون
لثلاثه مراحل التدريبيه طبقا لادوارهم
التطوعيه تبدا بالتدريب العام ولاحقا
التدريب التخصصي والتدريب الميدانيه
[تصفيق]
اول نوع من التدريب على وهو التدريب العام
اما النوع الثاني من التدريفه والتدريب
التخصصي فكل متطوع لا دور رئيسي في منطقه
تشغيليه معينه فاكيد لا تدريب خاص النوع
الثالث من التدريب الا وهو التدريب
الميداني
[موسيقى]
والنبي
[تصفيق]
على سبيل المثال هناك خدمات مساعده
المشجعين والمواصلات واشخاص مثلي يعملون
في مركز العمليات الاعلاميه ولكل دور من
هذه الادوار تدريب خاصه
[موسيقى]
اكتسب المتطوعون خلال التدريب الميداني
معلومات مفصله عن الملاعب الثمانيه التي
ستعقد بها مباريات بطوله كاس العالم بما
فيها مهام هذه الملاعب الوظيفيه وهويتها
الثقافيه
تماما هذا الملعب هو احد الملاعب
الايقونيه حيث يجسد تصميمه احد اشكال
تقاليد الشعب القطري
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان تصميم هذا الملعب سيساعد
المتطوعين وحتى الزوار الذين سياتون الى
هنا على فهم رساله القطريين والتي ترتبط
بتعزيز قيم الاستدامه ومشاركه الاخرين حيث
سيتم توزيع المواد التي تم استخدامها
لبناء هذا الاستاد او التبرع بها لاجزاء
اخرى من دول العالم الناميه وهذا في حد
ذاته يجعلنا ندرك ما تعنيه قطر ورسالتها
بتعزيز قيم الاستدامه ومشاركه المحبه لهذا
السبب يجب ان ناتي جميعا الى قطر ونعيشه
تجربه هذه البطوله الرائعه
[تصفيق]
الان امام ملعب لوسين حيث ساقوم بدور
تطوعي استاذ لوسيل فريد نوعه وهو احد اكبر
الملاعب ويمكن ان يتسع ل 80 الف شخصا
ويحتوي تصميمه اشكال الالوان العربيه كما
ان مظهره الخارجي يشبه الى حد كبير مصابيح
الفنار ولهذا انت ترى ان كل ملعب بطريقه
ما يستوح تصميمه من ثقافه العربيه
حيث الالوان والانماط وكل شيء يجدد
الاشياء التي نراها بانتظام هنا في العالم
العربي
واعتقد ان هذه الطريقه رائعه لمشاركه
العالم الاجزاء المهمه عن الثقافه التي
يجب على الجميع التعرف عليه
[موسيقى]
نتفاجا من من الشيء اللي احنا كنا نسمع
عنه واليوم نشوفها في الواقع فلما المتطوع
فقط سمع عن دوله قطر خلال هذه المراحل
السابقه اليوم بيكون متواجد وراح يشوف
دوله قطر راح يشوف الوطن العربي
[موسيقى]
حيث يسالون الكثيرون اين قطر كما ان احد
اكثر الاسئله التي دوما يتم سؤال عنها في
بلده هو هل يفرض علي نفس الحجاب بالطبع
الجواب لا والكثير من مثل هذا النمط من
الاسئله مثل السؤال عن مصطلح الشريعه التي
لا يعرفها الناس حقا ولا يفهمونها ولدي
فقط افتراضات بشانها اذا اعتقد ان مجرد
القدره على المجيء الى هنا سيغير الكثير
من تلك الاضطرابات التي لا تم الناس
وسيكتشفون كان الناس هنا ودول بغض النظر
عن كيفيه لباسهم او ما يرتدون فان الناس
هنا على استعداد لمساعدتك وهذا احد
الاشياء المميزه جدا في
العاب
المنطقه كما تعلمت كيفيه التعامل مع اشخاص
مختلفين من دول مختلفه ومن ثقافات مختلفه
وهذا كان احد اهدافي من وراء التطوع حيث
انني تعلمت منهم الكثير كما انني شاركت
معهم ثقافه كاثلبلين
[تصفيق]
ينفع
[موسيقى]
0 3
بيسالوني بعض الناس من اين لك كل هذا
الوقت للقيام بكل هذه الاشياء التي
تفعلينها والشيء الوحيد الذي اخبرهم به
بالتاكيد هو ان المتطوعين ليس لديهم
بالضروره الوقت لكنهم يمتلكون قلبا واذا
كانت هناك نيه صادقه في قلبك صدقني يمكنك
تخصيص كل الوقت اللازم للقيام بكل الاعمال
الصالحه التي يتعين عليك القيام بها وكذلك
لمساعده في جعل العالم مكانا افضل لك ولي
وللاجيال القادمه مرحبا بكم في قطر مرحبا
بكم في هذا العالم العربي الرائع شكرا
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم سعاده السيد حسن الذوادي الامين
العام للجنه العليا للمشاريع والارث
نشكركم على وقتكم الثمين في هذه اللحظات
الاخيره قبل انطلاق هذه البطوله ونقدر لكم
تلبيتكم للدعوه نبدا مما ختمنا به في
الفيلم الذي عرضناه خلال هذه الحلقه التي
طلعتم عليه عندما قالت هذه المتطوره
الاتيه من مكان بعيد وهو نفس الكلام الذي
يقوله كثر من المتطوعين اهلا بكم في قطر
اهلا بكم في هذا العالم العربي الرائع كما
ذكرت بكلماتها ان يتقدم قربت نصف مليون من
المتطوع من المختلفه العالم
للعمل مجانا في هذا المنديال ما الذي
يمثله بالنسبه لكم اي رساله يحملها وكيف
ترى انه كان منظم
رساله بالنسبه لنا هي الرساله اللي بدينا
فيها مشوارنا نحنا دائما اولا في البدايه
قلنا ان هذه بطوله عربيه
بطوله تستطيع ان ايضا تبني جسور
التعارف ما بين شعوب العالم وكان تقطع
اساسيه بالنسبه لنا اييي من اول يوم قدمنا
في الملف كان مؤمنين قوه كره القدم وكاس
العالم بشكل عام على نهايه استطيع ان
يتقرب ما بين الشعوب
فلما شفنا اليوم اقبال الناس واخبار
المتطوعين بهذا الشخص بهذا الاعداد
الكبيره من جميع انحاء العالم اثبتت لنا
شيء واحد ان فعلا
همم بالرغم الاختلافاتنا لان في اشياء
جمعنا الرياضه بشكل عام لها القدره على ما
نتجمع ما بين الشعوب
المنظمين المتطوعين اللي جاؤوا اللي بنو
على هذا الاساس اللي اللي سخر وقتهم بس ما
تفضلتي من دون اي مقابل على اساس نجوم
يعطوني يكون موجودين في اول بطوله عربيه
اعتقد بالنسبه لناس سخنت الكلمه اللي
قلناها بدايه مشوار
لا شك بالنسبه لنا طبعا هذا تعليمين انا
في وجهه نظري نجاح اي بطوله احد العناصر
الاساسيه والرئيسيه هم المتطوعين لان هم
الاشخاص اللي راح يكونون على تواصل بشكل
كبير مع الجمهور هم الاشخاص لهالحين همم
وشغفهم واحتمامهم همم وايمانهم باللي قاعد
يادونه
الجماهير راح يحصلون اشخاص
بالنسبه لي انا يمكن عنصر جدا مهم وجنس
همم نجاح البطولات اي بطوله ايا كان
شفناها في روسيا البطوله العربيه او
البطوله العربيه اليوم تتكلم على موضوع
المتطوعين اعتقد ما يقارب من 50% من همم
المتطوعين موجودين عندنا لهم 20,000 من
الوطن العربي همم يعني كان دائما كانت
الفكره موجوده عندنا ان الوطن العربي يرحب
بالعالم على الارض ولا قطر جميل همم
اعوذ بك سيد حسن وبذلك الى البدايات
انت كنت هنا وحضرت منذ البدايه في تقديم
الملف كنت الرئيس ستنفيذي في لجنه ملف قطر
اتحدث عن سنه 2010 ما الذي جعل باعتقادك
الملف القطري يفوز امام دول كبيره خاصه مع
من لا يزال يشكك في جداره واحقيه هذا
الملف ولحد الان للحظات الاخيره
اللي كانت موجوده فين في نجاح البطوله
بالنسبه لنا كانت
عده عناصر العنصر الاول والاساسي نحن فعلا
انه بدانا في الملف بس ما ذكرت همم قبل
شوي كان ملف عربي بالدرجه الاولى شرق او
صديق قطري وما كان محصور فقط في دوله قطر
يعني هذا السبب انك موجود بدايات ساعتين
على اساس انه يكون في جماعه عربي ودعم
عربي للملف يعني من اول زيارات اللي قلنا
فيها كانت زياره لبيروت في شهر اربعه 2010
الاجتماع وتقديم الملف لوزاره الرياضه
العرب مع العلم انهم ما عندهم عيد دخل في
عالم كره القدم او تاثير في التصويت انا
ما سمعنا لهم على اساس ان نعزز وانا اكرس
فكره ان هذه البطوله العربيه فالدرجه
الاساسيه طالما كنا نتكلم
همم همم بصوت الوطن العربي وبفكره ان
الوطن ان الاوان الوطني العربي ان يكون
متواجد همم في استضافه الاحداث الكبرى
العالميه الكبرى النقطه الثانيه بالنسبه
لنا اعتقد كانت فريق العمل كان فريق العمل
فعلا جديد فريق عمل يمكن كان جديد على
عالم كره القدم الدوليه
اوقات كثيره كانها مدخل الاجتماعات محل
كان يعرفنا
كان في فترات كثيره كان ممكن نشوف استهزاء
بعد بعد الحدث
الرغم من الناس ما كانت تعرفنا لكن كنا
داخلين بهدف الفوز لكنه مبتكر- كانها انه
نفتكر الافكار الجديده في كيفيه طرح الملف
كيفيه التواصل مع الناس بدانا بدايه
المشوار ما احد كان يعرفنا انتهينا في
2010 مع ال في القراءه المرحله هذه لا
الحمد لله اصبح جميع اعضاء الفريق معروفين
لدى العالم على كره القدم دوليه فريق
العمل كان فريق شاب بقياده سعد الشيخ محمد
كان فريق
وكان فريق همم مبتكر ويمكن اضافه جديده او
في نقطه جديده كانت اساسيه بالنسبه
للانجليزيه همم فها نفسها الربط عن نبني
علاقات مقربه مع مع ناس كثار كان عنصر جدا
اساسي مهم طبعا هذا نظرنا الموضوع الفني
للملف لا شك انها في البدايات كان يعني
كان الناس ينظرون الى ملف قطر ان فيه
صعوبات كثيره بس كعدت ما استطعنا ان ان
نحول الصعوبات الى همم ايجابيات ولكن
خلينا نشوف مثلا صور حجم البلد لكنها نشوف
انها لا صغر الحجم البلد تعطي فكره
استضافه جديده ما كانت موجوده في السابق
بعد ما الفرقه بتعنا السفر وتروح المنطقه
الى المنطقه يعني طبيعه البطولات فريق
ينهي مباراه في المدينه يسافر الى مدينه
اخرى ثم
كانت بالسياره
يعني
همم اللعيبه تكون عندهم اجهاد كبير لانه
في قطر واحد كل شيء لهم التركيز يكون فقط
في كره القدم
طبعا هذا
ايجابيات
يعني ايا كانت السلبيه بالنسبه لنا كنا
نقلها الى ايجابيات اذا كنا نشوف موقع
دوله قطر جغرافيه بالنسبه لنا فسهل الوصول
الى دوله قطر وايضا من ناحيه البرودكاست
المباراه
البث نفسه فكانت كانت يعني الفتره موقعها
كان جيد والايجابي حيث ان اكبر عدد من
سكان العالم بدون يشوفون مباريات في اوقات
ما يقال
همم كل شيء نسبيا ولكن يقدرون يحضرون
مباريات في اوقات مناسبه بالنسبه لهم
فبالنسبه لنا يعني مثل ما ذكرت اي شيء كنا
نشوفها سلبي حولنا الى جميع
حراره الجو ايضا وموضوع تغيير المونديال
من الصيف الى الشتاء
نقطه اساسيه
استاذ حسن يعني سواء بالنسبه
للحراره لانه تم استخدام الاتكييف للملاعب
رغم انه تم الاجابه على الاشياء لكن المهم
جدا انه نقطه واحده احنا بنضل بدايه كنا
حريصين وكنا
ملتزمين فان البطوله هي بطوله فتره الصيف
لانها كانت عندنا التكنولوجيا تبريد
موجوده عندنا ملاعب اسالنا الاستاذ نادي
السد موجود وجربناها وكنا جايين على تطوير
النظام التبريد هذا بحيث انه يكون همم اول
شيء يتم تطويرها من ناحيه همم التبريد
نفسه يكون فعال اكثر من ناحيه استخدام
الطاقه ان يكون فعال اكثر في استخدام
الطاقه ونكون في استخدامات اخرى غير تبريد
الملاعب لكن حديثنا على هذا الشيء من
الاول طبعا كعاده التكنولوجيا في اي شيء
كان في همم ما راح اقول استغراب لكن كان
في ناس مش مؤمنه في قدرتنا على انها تكون
التكنولوجيا فعاله فله هذا السبت تم اتخاذ
القرار من قبل العالم كره القدم مش من قبل
نحن هذا الشيء بس كان اتخاذ القرار العالم
كره القدم لنا
البطوله من فتره همم الصيف الى فتره
الشتاء تتحدث عن هذه النقطه بكل ايجابيه
لكن رغم ذلك هذه النقطه وغيرها من البطوله
في فصل الشتاء وليس في فصل الصيف ان كانت
على امتداد الشوارع في في اوبا وتمكين
جمهور عريض من متابعه هذه المباريات لا
زالت الانتقادات قائمه بما يمكن الرد على
ذلك
في البدايه يمكن لحد شهر 2 من 2010 محل
كما اخذ الجد
الكل كان يشوفنا مجرد ان قطر جاي يتقدم
الملف مجرد لتقديم الملف بس ما ذكرت لك
احنا كنا هدفنك عن الفوز لانه بالنسبه لهم
دوله عربيه جايه تقدم الاستضافه اكثر حدث
رياضي فهذا شيء خيال بالنسبه لهم من سابع
المستحيلات
تغيرت الامور في انجولا لما جيتوا قدمت
كلمه الى الاتحاد الافريقي
خاطبتهم وحكيت مشاعرهم وحكيت ال ال ال
الهجوم اللي كانوا هم يطلع لهم هم في فتره
تحضيرهم استضافه جنوب افريقيا لكاس العالم
انتقالات كثيره
التغيرات الامور وتغيرت المعادن بشكل كبير
الناس حسوا فعلا ان احنا بنافسين فعلا
جديين وعندنا قدره الفوز واموري كثير
متغير الفتره فلا شك اللي كان يعصرنا فديك
الفتره كان عارف ان الحبوبنا في الفوز
كانت كبيره واللي كان واللي كان يعاصر
ويتابع الموضوع اعرف ان احنا منافسين
حقيقيين وان احنا قدرتنا عن الفوز بس ما
قلت لك واقعيه وامانه في الفوز واقعيه
لما فزنا من اول يوم بدت الهجمه الشرسه
وانا اعتقد في وجهه نظري احد اهم الاسباب
في الهدم الشرسه في الموضوع هذا انه
استنكار استهجان للعالم الخارجي ما كان
يحاكي قصه الملف وما كان يشوف يعني ايش
اللي جبنا فيه ان كيف ممكن دوله عربيه
تفوز على امريكا يعني في استقرار
على الناس كثير بتقول كيف كيف يعني
على امريكا
اعتقد احد اهم الاسواق في هذا الموضوع انه
عندهم فكره موجوده
غرست في العالم الغربي على مرحله اجيال
قصور سواكنشوفها في طريقه تجسيد العرب في
الافلام في الكتب في الروايات ايا كانت
باستثناءات بس بشكل عام كانت دائما فكره
ان ناس غير متحضرين او ناس
الايجابيه الوحيده الموجود عندهم هو المال
مش لنا ناس فعلا
ليس لديه المال هو بالضروره المتخلف لكن
نظره سيد حسن يعني تتحدث عن انها تتكرست
ومنذ زمن بعيد لكن للاسف رايناها في
الاعلام الحر لا زالت رسوم
صدمه لنا كاجور عربي يعني ما الذي يفسر
ذلك استمرار هذا الموضوع
الدرجه الاولى اول شيء
استهجان بعض الناس او او استغراب بعض
الناس استنكار ان احنا فزنا في منافسه
يعني بالنسبه للناس كثار مثلا بطولات
السابقه ان كان ان كانت انعطت مثلا اذا
كانت تكلم على كوريا واليابان حتى ان كنت
تتكلم على جنوب افريقيا في البطولات هذه
لما راحت راحت خلينا نقول بهبه
ان بس بالنسبه لنا احنا دخلنا المناف
الشريف
بجداره انتزعناها بايمان ان هذه حق مشروع
لاي دوله اي كانت وبالذات الوطن العربي
بالنسبه للناس كثار هذا الموضوع يعني ما
كان المكان مقبول بالنسبه لكتاب منه السيد
حسن انه استمرار هذه الحمله هذا التشكيك
الى حد اللحظه خلص نحنا على بعض ايام
المونديال ماذا ترون فيه
هي هي بالنسبه لهم
ما الذي يريدونه
فيها اهداف مختلفه المساله طبعا في
البدايه كان في حمله على اساس انه ينتزعون
مونديال من عندنا والحمد لله الحمد لله
بكل صراحه لكن كان في ايضا يعني
بعض الناس ايضا في العبادات السياسيه تقام
ايضا على اراضيها ويشتغل لهم مثل الموضوع
بالنسبه لهم كجه
همم من الحديث ومن المعلومات اللي جاءت
لان بعضها لا في في كانت اهداف سياسيه
داخليه موجوده بالنسبه لهم بعضهم كانت
امور اقتصاديه يعني تتعلق في بعض الامور
اقتصاديه موجوده عندهم اساس ان الشاشات
الشاشات اللي موجوده تتطلب كهرباء
يعني بدل ما تكون هذه الاسباب
تحججوا بحجه بحجه اخرى موجوده بالنسبه لهم
فليبقى اقول انك بس بشكل عام
كونان وطن عربي دوله عربيه استطاعتنا
الندوه تنتزع منه هذا الشيء هذا كانت شيء
امر غير مرغوب بالنسبه له وبالاضافه بهذا
الشيء ارجع واقول لك من خلال الفتره المره
خلال اخر 10 سنين همم بالنسبه همم
اي اي همم اشاعه تقال سلبيه همم ترسخ في
بالناس لان هي التواكب ال- ال- ال- الفكره
النبطيه اللي موجوده لهم سهل ان شخص ماشي
مثلا في شوارع انجلترا او شوارع فرنسا ان
يصدق ان مثلا همم
ان فزنا بسبب الفساد عندنا يقولون لا
والله هذا كان ملف فعلا جديد بالفوز سهل
بالنسبه
الاساسيه لهذا السبب
كانت من احد اهم الاسباب والدوافه ان احنا
نقدم على صرافه المونديال وسعينا وحاربنا
على استضافه المولديان لتغيير الفكره
النمطيه اللي موجوده ومترسخه عندنا
اقف عندها السيد حسن يعني الان انت تقول
بانكم انتزعتم هذا الحق ماذا انتم فاعلون
بذلك يعني الجميع يتذكر بان الرياضه لها
وقع كبير جدا المانيا بعد المونديال الذي
حدث هناك استطاع التغيير ال- ال- هذه
الصوره النمطيه التي كانت توصل بها على
انها المانيا النازيه نفس الموضوع بالنسبه
لي روسيا والاخرى ماذا انتم فاعلون بهذا
ال- ال- الالتزاع لهذا الحلقه الان هل
تعتقدون فعلا بانه يمكن ان يحرك الامور
الراكده هؤلاء الناس مليون واكثر من
مشجعين الذين همم المنطقه ما الذي يجدونها
بماذا ستعيدونهم هل ستغير ولو قليلا هذه
الصوره النمطيه اذا مشينا على التاريخ
كره القدم كاس العالم عنده القدره على هذا
الشيء
في المانيا وغيرت 2006 كان عندها هدفين
ايجابيين بالنسبه للمانيا الهدف الاول
تغيير اسطوره النمطيه للخارج الى المانيا
ومن هدف او او الفائده الثاني للاستفاده
منها تغيير صور النبطيه للالمان نفسه ما
بين المانيا الغربيه هذه النقطه جدا
الاساسيه كنا نتكلم فيها جامد
2018 روسيا الناس اللي من خارج كان عندهم
رؤيه معينه عن الرؤوس وصل الى روسيا الشعب
الروسي غير الفكره اللي موجوده بالنسبه
للناس اللي موجودين على الاقل همم للزوار
يقول ان قوه كاس العالم بشكل عام هي في
تقارب الشعوب وتقارب الجماهير بينهم وبين
بعض هذه هذه يمكن بالنسبه يعني سر نجاح
البطوله وتصير تغيير الفكره النبطيه اولا
الناس من الخارج يشوفون طبعا يشاهدونها
شاشاتهم راح يشوفهم دوله متحضره راح
يشوفوا الناس من جميع الاطياف جميع
الاجناس فرحانين وجايين همم يشجعون او
تكون كرنفال كروي وكرنافول ثقافي موجود
لكن بدرجه اساسيه الشعوب اللي تيجي الناس
اللي كبدت على السفر وجات لاول مره في
الوطن العربي بعضهم يمكن اول مره يزودوا
يزور الوطن العربي والنعاصر والعاشر الوطن
العربي وبالمعاشره والتعامل
ويمكن يعني راح يتعرفون على الثقافه
العربيه على الكرم العربي على الفخر
العربي الموجود عندنا على غزاره الثقافه
اللي موجوده عندنا هذه يمكن نقطه اساسيه
بالنسبه لنا همم في في تغيير الصوره
النمطيه اللي موجوده ومن ثم بدايه بدايه
البرنامج يعني تكلمنا عنه المتطوعين يعني
ما يقارب بال 50% من المتطوعين من 20,000
متطوعه من العشره الاف الجنسيه العربيه
موجودين اليوم اللي جيتهم الاكوادور او لا
ياتي من البرازيل اللي بعضهم اول مره في
هذه المنطقه كلمه كل كل مصور لهم بالنسبه
لهم اللي يشاهدون في التلفزيون وفي
الاخبار عن الوطن العربي لما يجوا يقابل
المصري او يقابل التونسي او يقابل الجزائر
او السودان او الطريقه والسعودي ويكون فيه
نوع من الصداقه نوع من التعارف هذه لها
ورق كبير جدا جدا جدا
وكلنا امل وكلنا ثقه ان اللي يزور قطر
وتعامل مع جميع اللي موجودين هنا راح
يتحولون السفراء بالنسبه لنا ولسفراء
الوطن العربي لما يرجعون الى بلدينهم الان
عن الانسان
مليار دولار على بطوله كاس العالم
البريطانيه يعني نحن نتحدث عن قرابه 20
مره اضعاف مونديال روسيا 2018 يعني بما
يمكن الرد على ذلك
الرقم
غير دقيقه
ال 200 مليار هو رقم يجمع جميع مشاريع
البنيه التحتيه لدوله قطر
العالم
لكاس العالم
نقطه واحده جدا الاساسيه ان لا همم لا
نحمل الدوله متطلبات في بنيه تحتيه لا
تحتاجها من اول يوم نبدا الارث كان موجود
في بلدنا مبدا الاستفاده من البطوله
الاستفاده القصوى لهذا السبب جميع
المشاريع اللي موجود البنيه التحتيه لم
تبنى كاس العالم
نفرق ما بين البنيه التحتيه وما بين
الملاعب فيه موجوده
اتكلم على مجمل
ده اللي بتتكلم عنه 200 مليار من 200
مليار يتضمن جميع موجوده تطوير تطوير
الشوارع تطوير همم المترو او بناء محطه
المترو اذا كلم على المطار اذا كنا نتكلم
على نظام اتصالات اللي موجوده
في نهايه الامر يصب في صالح للمواطن
القطري وسستفيد من حتى الاجيال القادمه
كاس العالم عام اساسي
لمساعد الدفع عجله التنميه اللي موجوده
والاستعجال وانجاز المشاريع باوقات همم
قياسيه في بعض المشاريع مثلا المشروع
المترو ولكن في نهايه الامر مشاريع هذه
مشاريع تواكب رؤيه قطر 2030 وايضا همم همم
رؤيه البنيه التحتيه او او خطط البنيه
التحتيه وخطط تطوير البلد بشكل عام يعني
بس ارجع موضوع الملاعب نفسها طبعا مهم جدا
حتى في الملاعب كان عندنا ارز او مبدا
الارث كان موجود حتى في تصميم الملاعب
بناء الملاعب
تواصلنا مع الجماهير اللي موجوده او الناس
اللي موجودين اللي ساكنين السكان الحقيقي
اللي موجودين حوالين الملاعب كلهم في فتره
التصميم الملاعب تواصلنا معهم سمعنا منهم
ايش اللي ممكن يتوفر في الملاعب يمكن
نخدمهم هذه المنطقه حاولنا نوفرها بعض هذه
الاشياء في بعض الملاعب نبدا انزال همم
كراسي الملاعب مقاعد الملاعب من همم
موجوده 40,000 ملعب الاستاذ البيت 60.000
ملابس
همم على نفس الاعداد يعني او تصميم في
الاساس ان راح ننزل اعداد الحراسي الى
اعداد احنا شوفنا محتاجينها الاحتياجاتنا
احنا في المستقبل سواء كانت احتياجات
الدوله القطري او تنظيم البطولات العالميه
بس يمكن احب ان اقول نقطه مهمه جدا اساسي
هذه كانت خطه همم خطه الارث اللي موجوده
في جميع الملاعب خلال عشر سنين مرتين فيها
استضاف احداث عالميه بدانا مباريات وديه
عالميه البرازيل همم البرازيل الارجنتين
انجلترا البرازيل واسبانيا الى اخرين
وبعدين بدنا نستضيف احداث عالميه او
مباريات وليها عالميه كاس العالم للانديه
2019 اللي يمكن يعني جميع العناصر اللي
كانت فيه بالنسبه لنا كانت مباريات
تجريبيه لكن ايضا استفدنا منها نشفنا في
شغف فيه فيه رغبه في الوطن العربي في
الاحداث العالميه الكبرى يمكن ختمناها اخر
تجربه فعليه كانت موجوده بالنسبه لنا هي
كاس العرب كاس العرب في 2021 شوف لنا فيه
اقبال كبير في اقبال على عدد الملاعب او
حجم
الملاعبنا اقليميه او غير ذلك
العام الاسيويه موجوده لا شك يعتقد همم
طموح استضافه الالعاب الاولمبيه على حسب
العلميه موجوده ايضا لا زالت حيه
الاستفاده من هذه همم
موجوده
الاساسيه الدنيا
همم البيان الذي اصدرته الفيفا الخاصه
اللي همم الفرق بضروره التركيز على اللاعب
وابعاد السياسه مره اخرى عن الايديولوجيا
والسياسه وغير ذلك 10 احداث اوروبيه
استعجلت وقدمت بيان المشترك حول هذا همم
الموضوع
وترى بضروره الضغط ضروره مواصله الضغط حتى
خارج همم الملاعب يعني كيف تقيمون انتم
هذا البيان وما موقفكم ايضا من ايه نشاطات
قد تقوم بها فعلا هذه همم الفرق
والاتحادات الكرويه على هامش هذه البطوله
علاء الدين بكل بساطه على البيان اللي طلع
ان
يعني في نهايه الامراض هم احنا بدنا قناه
الامر
الاسباب اللي هم يستخدمونها او الحجج اللي
يستخدمونها من ناحيه الانتقادات التي
تطالنا ان كانت الحقوق الانسان والاخره
وكذا فما اعتقد ان في دوله نظيفه
قامت في دوله قطر في موضوع بالذات مثلا
نتكلم في تطبيق قوانين العماله الى اخرها
امور كثيره موجوده في استخدامه كره القدم
واستخدام كاس العالم همم
كعداء التطوير بشكل عام كنا نتكلم مثل ما
قلت لك على قوانين على بنيه تحتيه الى
اخرها وكذا همم
العالم بشكل كبير كنا دائما احنا يعني
مثلا العلاقات اللي موجوده وان كانت تطلع
تقارير موجوده من منظمات حقوقيه احنا
دائما كنا فاتحين يعني ابوابنا يعني انا
ما عندي مشاكل همم
اه اه نخاف منها مستحي منه مساله الاصرار
على هذه على هذا النوع من التصاريح على
تقدري يمكن همم الاستهلاك الموجود داخليا
عندهم لاي كانت الاهداف بالنسبه لهم احنا
بالنسبه لله الحمد افعالنا موجوده تثبت
وموجوده على ارض الواقع تثبت اللي جبنا
فيه تثبت همم تطورنا والتزامنا
حقوق الانسان
الحنيف وهو اصلا يفرض علينا احنا واللي
جاب لنا فيه في الفتره الاخيره همم وارجع
اقول في نهايه الامر اعتقد لما لما لما
الجمهور راح يجيء يوم الجمهور راح يشاهد
يعاصر لما راح يتعامل مع
الجمهور القطري العربي اللي موجود هم راح
يكون عامل الفارق وهم راح يردون على هذه
البيانات الموجوده فانا ايمان التمام
البطوله بنجاحها راح يكون مع مع
تغيير الفكره انماطيه الموجوده للجماهير
مثل ما ذكرته السابق كانهم راح يكون
السفراء راح يروحون وراح يتكلمون عن دوله
قطر وعن الوطن العربي
الاوكرانيه
يعني بشكل مستمر ايضا الجماهير العربيه
ايضا تقول بانه من حقها اذا الان ان ترفع
شعارات مناصره ايضا للقضيه الفلسطينيه وهي
القضيه الاهم بالنسبه للعالم همم العربي
همم تم فتح خط طيران من قبل قطر
لجمهور المشجعين دي يتمكنوا من حضور هذه
البطوله مباشره همم
ماذا تقول في هذا هل ستكون متسامحين في
هذه الشعارات كيف سيكون الموضوع بالنسبه
لكم هل يشكل حرجا بالنسبه لكم عفوا الحرج
همم
لن تسمحوا لانهم بالنسبه المطلق لا تريدون
خلط الرياضه باي موضوع
الشعارات من عدم هذا الموضوع
ممكن اتكلم احنا بس الموضوع يتعلق بشكل
اساسي يعني اللي يصير في حرم الملعب هذا
شيء يتعلق في الفيفا والفيفا هي اللي تضع
المعايير انا يمكن قلت لك لما قلت لك في
البدايه هي الرغبه في عدم خلطه السياسيه
بالرياضه ولكن في نهايه الامر اتخاذ
الاجراءات واتخاذ القرارات هذا امر محصور
عند الفيفا وفي متطلبات موجوده عندنا
تعاقديه وقانونيه ملزومين فيها احنا ففي
هذا الامر موضوع مثل ما قلت لك التنظيم في
الحرم الملعب موجود عند الفيفا اا
بالنسبه طبعا ان احنا يعني همم بوجود
الشعب الفلسطيني وجود الفلسطيني حضور
بطولاتهم هذا الشيء يفرحنا يعني هم
موجودين معنا همم هذه في نهايه الامر مثل
ما قلنا بطوله عربيه وتواجد جميع
المواطنين الوطن العربي على ارض دوله قطر
في احتفاليه اللي هي احتفاليتهم هذا
بالنسبه لنا شيء جدا لكن هناك بانه سيف ذو
حدين حضور الجماهير الفلسطينيه وتمكينها
من ذلك يسمح ايضا بحضور الجماهير
الاسرائيليه طبعا في استضافه الاحداث
الكبرى الاحداث العالميه الكبرى وبالاخص
كره القدم كاس العالم لكره القدم العالميه
فنضروري جدا استضافت جميع
او جميع الجماهير من جميع البلدان او ايا
كانت
عجي من اي منطقه في العالم هذا نقطه جدا
اساسيه والتزام موجوده على اي دوله نظيفه
بالنسبه لنا احنا طبعا بالاضافه لهذا
الشيء احنا كدوله
عندها خبره طويله في استضافه الاحداث
العالميه الكبرى في الجميع مرحب فيه ولكن
كنا حريصين مثل قلت لك كل الحرص على ان
الجمهور الفلسطيني يستطيع ان يكون موجود
ومتواجد مع ابناء الوطن العربي
للاحتفاليه لبطوله عربيه موجوده على ارض
الوطن العربي
للسؤال عن موضوع تامين همم من كل النواحي
يعني من ناحيه تنظيميه حتى من ناحيه روسيا
مثلا مره اخرى اعلنت انه بعد المونديال
تعرضت ل 25 مليون هجمه سايبانيه في هذا
الموضوع ما هي تحضيراتكم
بمناسبه تحضيرات الامنيه همم 2013 همم
شكلت لجنه اللجنه الامنيه برئاسه رئيس
الوزراء وزير الداخليه فيها جميع الجهات
الامنيه موجوده فيها وبدانا في التحضير
مخطط الامنيه 2013
الامور الفنيه الامنيه ولكن من من النقاط
الاساسيه الموجوده احنا كنا حاضرين في
جميع البطولات العالميه افراد موجودين
اليوم مش هيكون عناصر الرئيسيه في الفرق
الامنيه اللي موجوده على ارض الواقع اليوم
كانت حاضر يمكن بطولات عالميه على شتى
مجالاتها سواء كانت مثلا الشامبيونز ليجا
الدوري الاوروبي البطوله الاوروبيه مثلا
في 2016 في فرنسا لما كان في همم
المشاكل اللي صارت ما بين الجماهير
الانجليزيه والجماهير الروسيه يمكن ما
يحضر الجميع
ما تعرف بس همم مساعد القائد المنشئه
القائد المنشاه في الفتره في الفتره هو
قطري موجوده هناك ذهب الخمره وكان مش مجرد
يعني همم
مشاهده
الخبرات من البطولات العالميه هذا هذا احد
الاشياء اللي عملنا عليها طبعا وضع الخطه
2013 الى الان همم الاستعانه بالخبرات
العالميه ايضا مثل في خمارات عالميه او في
جهات عالميه استعانه خبراتنا الاستعانه
ايضا ببعض القوات والخبرات العالميه اللي
هو ايضا شيء طبيعي موجود الخطه
السيبيرانيه طبعا موجود الان اعتقد على
حسب الطلائي همم يمكن من من افضل الانظمه
اللي موجوده في العالم
همم
واعتقد الحمد لله يعني احنا الان واثقين
في ان الخطه الامنيه اللي موجوده
وتوفير الكوادر الامنيه اللي موجوده همم
كافيه همم نقطتين الاولى كافيه الى تامين
البطوله ولكن النقطه الثانيه ايضا
التحضيرات اللي موجوده همم جعلت من كثير
من القوات الامنيه الخارجيه تسعه الى انها
تكون جزء من همم الفرق الامنيه اللي
موجوده لاكتساب بالخبرات اللي همم
راح يطلعون عليها خلافات البطوله قبل ان
اختم معك السيد حسن يعني انا عارف شعورك
الان في وشعوركم انتم الشباب الذين معكم
في اللجنه همم نرتاحون ام اكثر قلقا على
بعض ايام كيف انتم
مرتاحين ف- همم يجب على الاخرين ان يخلقون
ولكن فقط خالقين ف- اا اعتقد يعني ههه
ايضا يخلقه لا احنا امانه يعني ممكن اقول
لك اياها احنا موافقين لكن مقياس القلق
يعني او مقدار القلق لازم يكون موجود
انطلق خلينا نقول القلق الصحي اللي موجود
فخورين همم
اتمنى ان نبيض الوجه نتمنى من يعني وان
كان اوصل رسائل الجميع للعاملين اا في في
في هذه البطوله ان فعلا يعني
الكل يعمل بشغف يعني اليوم التالي بعد
المونديال ما هي خطبتكم هل ستاخذون اجازه
طويله ام ان
لكم جميعا
يعني يمكن
يمكن مده 13 سنه 18 ديسمبر بالنسبه لي هو
يعني التاريخ الوحيد اللي موجود امامي ما
خطط لاي شيء ما بعرف 18 ديسمبر
واعتقد بالنسبه للاخرين طبعا لا شك يمكن
نقطه مهمه اليها
الناس اكثر
همم قطر قطر
كاس العالم
لا الحمد انجازات قطر موجوده والكل يشهدها
همم كانت موجوده قبل كاس العالم كاس
العالم محطه وين كانت محطه مهمه محطه
رئيسيه في قصه دوله قطر ولكن
فيه خطط موجوده اذا كانت تكلم مثلا بسيط
في استضافه الاحداث الكبرى ذكرت في احداث
كوبرا ايضا
الى اخره وطبعا يعني
ااا في موجود يعمل رؤيه 2030
مستمرين في تحقيق رؤيه قطر 2030 اريد ان
اختم معك بهذه العباره قلت باننا سنصنع
التاريخ بمونديال قطر 2022 هذه المسؤوليه
كبيره
ما الذي يعني ذلك ما الذي تقصده ما الذي
يمكن ان تقدمه فعلا كارثه وللمنطقه
وللعالم من خلال هذا المنزله طبعا الارز
تركيزنا دائما انا دائما اشوف دائما اشوف
احنا الهدف الاساسي هو في البشر اولا
التغيير فكره انا معطيه اللي موجوده هاي
يعني
مهما اعيد واكررها ما اعطيها حقها تغيير
الفكره النبطيه اللي موجوده احنا ذكرنا
الهجمات اللي جايه لنا واجهناها اللي
دائما سهل بالنسبه للعالم الخارجي انه
يتهم اي شخص من الوطن العربي عربي همج غير
متحضرين الى اخره وكذا هذا اعتقد البطوله
هذه عامل اساسي لتغيير الفكره النمطيه ان
لم تكن في الاعلام فتكون البشر تكون
النائب الشخص للشعب للشعوب الجماهير اللي
جاء يتمثل الشعوب الشعوب الجماهير اللي
جايه راح تكون سفراء راح يكون سفراء
بالنسبه لنا لشعوبهم
فعلا يعني من من خلال السنين اللي فاتت
مسافرات من من من طلعاتي دائما اشوف في
ناس كثار اللي عاش واللي يعاشر والوطن
العربي اشد المدافعين عن الوطن العربي هذا
فرصه بالنسبه لنا مثل ما ذكر النبطيه
للوطن العربي نقطه اساسيه اذا كان نتكلم
في الخبرات اللي موجوده خبرات استضافه
اكبر حدث
عالمي في الرياضه الخبرات سواء كانت في
نظام التنظيم في في التنظيم سواء كانت في
السياحه سواء كانت في الاعلام الى اخره
وكذا الكوادر اللي موجوده سواء متعلقه
مباشره او غير مباشره بطريقه غير مباشره
في تنظيم كاس العالم هذه خبرات موجوده
باذن الله راح يتم في الوطن العربي راح
تساهم وتساعد وتعزز من تطوير
الكوادر والشباب العربي اللي موجود وخلق
فرس اخرى موجوده ونبني عليها وتكون فرصه
ولا بدنا نقدر نبني عليها في المستقبل
عربي كل وطن على حدا وايضا همم احنا جميعا
يعني
واحد يعني
الجماهير كيف تحمسونهم الناس التي وصلت
يعني بالفعل يعني يعني
بشكل رساله
هذه بطوله عربيه من الدرجه الاولى اول يوم
من مشوارنا من اول خطوه خططيناها دائما
كنا حارسين هذه هذه بطوله عربيه هذه
بطولتكم في نهايه الامر على ارض اولاد خطر
فالكل له ااا دور يلعبها في نجاح هذه
البطوله جماهيريا وتنظيميه جماهير العالم
انا اقول احنا يعني بالنسبه للعالم احنا
اكثر من الف ليله وليله نحن اكثر من
الصوره النبطيه اللي موجوده احنا وطن عربي
احنا الشعب عربي
فيه كم من المواهب وفي كم من من الفقر
والثقه وكم من الغزار الثقافيه اللي
موجوده اللي راح نبهر فيها العالم وراح
تنبهروا فيها نقول لهم اذا نستعدوا
لرؤيه صوره مغايره ربما للتي كرسها
الاعلام والافلام وغير ذلك على امتداد عيش
تجربه تاريخيه همم راح تكون الاولى في
حياتهم باذن الله همم لن تكون الاخره
اشكركم جزيل الشكر السيد حسن
اللجنه العليا
بتمنى لكم التوفيق الجميع ينتظر هذا
المونديال مونديال قطر مونديال كل العرب
ختام هذه الحلقه مشاهدينا الكرام من
برنامج القصه بقيه نعود ونلقاكم باذن الله
مع بقيه قصه جديده الاثنين القادم بخير
والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]